всем привет приветствую всем добрый
вечер и доброе утро стив я хотел
предложить сегодня тема для беседы
который касается бумажных книг и
электронных книг но также в процессе
подготовки я понял что я также буду
задавать вопросы о книгах и интернете в
общем-то противопоставления книга
интернета хорошо
далекий так что я думаю нашим зрителям
будет любопытно нас послушать я
подготовил несколько вопросов первый из
них стив что есть чтение как ты
понимаешь чтение что это такое
что из состояния
я думаю что теперь я это самое способ
[музыка]
сказать коммуницировать пасется не
общаться общаться я думать и говорить и
общаться но чтобы выручить
что то конечно через опыт да мы можем
выйти чуть много и и может быть в
конечном итоге это это опыт как который
нам помогает что-то учиться но мы не
можем иметь опыт все возможные ситуации
но через четыре
мы можем участвовать много опытах этого
и я и звонить мои русские немножко
очень долго говорить по-русски но когда
мы например я читаю книгу
а может быть роман в 19 века
я не могу участвовать в жизни и в 19
века но я могу через
через книгу я могу это сделать на счет я
не знаю я купила не знаю компьютер как
использовать компьютер окай я могу
ищет ютюбе
но я тоже и когда у меня есть опция
я могу если бы читать посмотреть видео
или титан днем предпочитаю читать это
быстрее я могу когда угодно опять читать
это удобный и эффективный economic ну да
и я думаю это самый мы думаем что у нас
есть компьютер с
я не знаю устройства но сама идея 4
писать-читать
я могу что-то ты бля
и как через четыре это это это и бежать
передать это фантастический и самый факт
что я читаю там есть много-много буквы
буквы и эти буквы станет смысл это для
меня это удивительный способ
коммуникации и
[музыка]
образованием разовыми образование
образование это самый эффективный способ
образовать да мне и не только и
в dmoz люди которые любит поэзию любит
роман или его читать книги я истории я
читаю и ги у историю середине азия
я не я могу узнать много это это
огромная вещь я думаю и и в россии в
коране есть люди которые не
и плохо читают и самой нашей жизни нашей
самой показатель сколько у вас будет в
жизни успех это уровень 4 люди которые
horn не все но статистически люди
которые хорошо читают них более успех в
профессиональной или академический или
и люди есть в каждой в качестве товара
есть 20 процентов людей которые не очень
хорошо читают мы говорим не очень много
читают да я понимаю стив если можно я
сейчас процитирую 1 философа
который зовут андрей baumaster он очень
популярен сейчас в украине
когда его спросили прочтения он сказал
что когда мы читаем мы где шифру им
символы и это требует концентрации жди
не это искусство расшифровки знаков и
человек может себя реализовать если у
него есть коды
знаковым системам любить можно услышать
что ты думаешь по поводу этому потому
что мне особенно интересно поскольку ты
человек который читает на нескольких
письменности в том числе на фарси и над
на арабском и рублёв и и так далее вот
не особенно интересно узнать у тебя
поскольку ты видишь этого с точки зрения
разных знаковых систем разного систем
может быть я побед черецкий латинский
арабский пензе это тоже of batman .
сложная и другой стороны есть и рублей
ну для меня это систем писания и
надо привыкнуть нашей музыке наши мост
систем для dos с создания
мы говорим паттернов потому и
и мы можем это сделать и ли вы или
оливки или геев и карельские отрезки и
и конечно тем более мы используем
[музыка]
тыльной систем тем комфортно я читал
лучше по на 30 темпо керенский хотят или
не очень сложно но
тем не менее если я читали польский
который я не знаю так как хорошо кружки
но погиб
иски немножко сложны и арабские тем
более и китайский тебе боль это зависит
от сколько ты уже я читать ее то есть
если надо дать мозг возможность
привыкнуть и
шаг за шагом ножки
будет я думаю что не зависит от детский
корейский корейский китайский что угодно
факт что мы как как животный да ей
несколько сотни тысяч лет мы никогда не
читал и сейчас мы имеем это возможности
я думаю что тот факт что нашей музыке
сейчас имеют это это способ это это
навыки
я это огромный огромный огромный событие
события савинцев нашли наше развитие как
существ как вида как вида
хорошо тогда позволь я перейду к
следующему вопросу если твоя точки
зрения разница когда ты читаешь книги
бумажные книги и когда ты считаешь
электронные книги и если вы тебя ставишь
ли ты себе целью в конечном счете читать
книги всегда бумажные
на самом высоком я предпочитаю тетрадь и
бумажные деньги
если я читаю для удовольствия читаю
по-английски или по-французски или даже
по-русски
когда я читаю книги где я и где я я знаю
95 процентов слов-то минимум это минимум
если есть более чем не знаю 5 слов
каждая страница которой я не знаю это не
до вас нет я не люблю даже если не вляет
на мое понимание это не знаю что это для
этого когда я читаю по я
язике на языком которой я не очень
хорошо знаю я предпочитаю читать айпаде
апатия я
12 на 5 слов france слушать и т.с.
удаление по-русски например или
по-арабски где вообще описания отношения
с произношение и поэтому и в электронные
видео есть много преимуществ
преимущество преимущество но если я и но
читать как читать бумаги
но все это все-таки если я сейчас мы не
можем участвовать кого но когда я
путешествую я предпочитаю не бумажно
потому что я могу я не хочу
береги затем одондо тогда триаде
я люблю читать если я должен каждый раз
два три книги и когда я будет купить
книги и я у меня есть очень удобно я
могу купить что угодно немедленно когда
я читаю я не знаю в интернете если
интересные книги я могу это книги по
английски и по польски и по-русски про
что угодно купить немерено и начинать я
читать это очень удобно но читать как
читать я предпочитаю кидать бумаги
хорошо как ты думаешь зачем вообще
бумажные книги в эпоху
информации я объясню дело в том что
где-то в 90 е годы во всяком случае на
постсоветском пространстве
многие учителя и ученые считали что
книги вымрут
и люди перестанут в будущем читать
книжки вместо этого они будут смотреть
видео они будут больше слушать то есть
получать информацию другим путем но
похоже что мы видим что книги живы все
живы и в общем то почему так как ты
думаешь я думаю что мы
нам нужно потому что сегодня слизней и
есть много
отвлечения отличие от
лечение от значения отвлечения отдать и
отвлечений это конечно есть и плюс и
минус
мы можем немедленно дескать или
посмотрите пейте что случилось так много
отвращения
педаль книги когда вы
и содержание и может выйти в другой мир
в другой ситуации ты можешь другой мир
книг нет все таки это не будет мне можно
я не будет и еще я не знаю но это очень
важный
активность нам нужно нам нужно
что меня спустя вот уже несколько лет
практики
учебу изучение языка полинке поражает
это что link ведь подразумевается
почтение и я чувствую что за последние
годы
линк помогает мне больше
концентрироваться
чтение помогать не концентрироваться и
он помогает развивать мое воображение
потому что как то говорить стив а когда
ты читаешь книгу
ты убегаешь от реальности ты
путешествуешь в другом времени не и мне
кажется что это интересная мысль что в
интернете знание всегда отрывками
урывками чуть-чуть здесь чуть-чуть там
так далее но книга когда особенно это
толстая книга в ней есть сюжет и и там
нет отвлечение дистрикта ты никуда не
можешь кликнуть и это огромное
путешествие которое ты пройдешь
концентрации мне кажется так да и kia k9
читал я есть и каждый раз когда я смотрю
на май
я вспомню этом лиге я люблю вот роль 100
начать изучение языка я не хочу читать
книги
много слов кота я не знаю и для этого
раздражают и килобайт ма да но я хочу
вы ищет что я могу тебе дать по лбу
мазни из твоего опыта сколько примерно я
знаю что от языка как языка к языку эта
цифра будет изменяться сколько примерно
должно быть у тебя слов пассивном
словарном запасе чтобы ты считал
бумажной книги
много-много но это зависит
знаешь ли мы считаем каждый века здесь
слова слова слова я и так едва до
до этого по-русски базе счастье
я не знаю но много все таки много если
если есть это сок например готова
человек который знает словацкий язык
может читать другой славянский язык без
знания и мои
который который знает итальянский
это испанский если ты нет такого is
literally которые не знать до знает
славянские языки читает ручки
но во многом долго-долго хорошо стив
скажи пожалуйста насколько люди во
первых не кажется ли тебе что сегодня
люди читают меньше чем они читали
допустим 30 лет назад и на примере
канады
например мне интересно узнать ходит ли
люди публичной библиотеке популярной ли
они или нет популярны ли книжные
магазины именно где
бумажной книги я знаю я я я не могу
сказать но библиотеки популярны люди
идут на активность вокруг люди читают
люди там не будет не будет и будет
давать его любят и это очень хорошая
вещь очень ворочалась
книжный магазин к сожалению более более
есть огромный огромные
чай зеленый и
и маленькие бумажные книги магазине боли
боли не существует но если я пойду и
сейчас с к видам не так много я думаю
того
отлит я не знаю я сейчас я немного га я
пойду если не необходимость купить люди
идут назад 0
но людей идет но большой как ты думаешь
я думаю но статистика говорит что мы
стали считать меньше чем мы читали
как-то то безусловно потому что
большинство особенно дети
поскольку у меня теперь есть ребенок
многие родители думают о том как
приучить ребенка к чтению и отучить от
вот этого и это большая большой вопрос и
как ты думаешь будет ли будут ли люди
читать больше будущем пройдет ли
наступит ли отход назад опять к книге
либо все больше больше гаджета все
больше больше
виртуальной реальности во первых
что видишь использовать читать это
чтение
маленький я я вижу новички у меня есть
пять
[музыка]
читают все все читают все я купил книг
иногда
бумажные книги иногда кендо
но читают и
сильно 7 считает и
о боже по-русски даже меня сложно с
этими всеми родственными дарвина но это
это
это невестка это называется невестка
помогу жена сына невестка наверно
комментарий в комментариях кто будет
смотреть обязательно напишет как это
называется я не очень я думаю что у нас
и общество
крайняя тоже есть люди которые читают и
люди которым нет и люди которые хорошо
читают любит читать и люди которые не
кого же и это это для этого я думаю что
в школах
поле самый важный это помогать ученики и
хорошо читать быстро
хорошего читать это самое влиятельное
это читать читать и люди которые не
[музыка]
учиться в школу хорошо читать они тоже
может работать будет но я я работал
много людей это заводов там нашей беседе
заводов люди которые очень хорошо знаю
машине и все года не очень хороший тают
о чем может сказать
успешный а профессиональные успехи у них
есть работа но статистически люди
которые прочитают имеют меньший успех в
жизни это мне все будет хорошо читать и
неуспех но кстати да здесь тически до
700 пустив что ты думаешь о чтении
нескольких книг одновременно и читаешь
ли ты
несколько книг одновременно на разных
языках сейчас я изучаю и арабские тогда
будет читать учебник или это учебник
истории надо опять и опять 1 может еще
исполнить я никогда
минерально арабский но роман я не могу
если я читаю романы не читаю книгу
история
концентрировать на данном языке
на других хорошо вот интересно скажи
пожалуйста
важно ли для тебя fiction или
non-fiction имеет ли это значение и для
тех кто учит язык для те
я думаю это вопрос вкус да я предпочитаю
женщин я вот
меня для меня история это очень
интересно но я буду читать книги о
история или история среды я это очень
интересно очень интересно влияния
иран на имбе или или отношения между
турецкий для меня или турецкие культура
иранских все это очень интересно и
поэтому я предпочитаю читать я много
чего хочу знать и был я .
иностранный язык я люблю люди раз
нисколько не надо читать это люди
сегодня не это это старый язык
тебе помогает я совсем не
и я думаю что когда мы изучаем
иностранные языки
это понемножку нереальные цели это наши
наши язык-то поэтому я люблю где-то
19 века в россии это часто май
выдаваться люди и земель другие времени
ситуации поэтому и фикседа fiction
сказки эфир я читаю это по-французски
итальянские русские и очень-очень-очень
английский я читаю
хорошо я просто хотел добавить от себя
что последний роман который я считал на
итальянском языке это роман
барселонского автора и я просто хотел
сказать насколько красивый язык когда
fiction эти фразы это удивительно
красивые сравни и ого синонимы
а плюс к этому как-то fiction когда
художественную литературу это называется
художества литература есть диалоге между
людьми и они все равно иногда общаются
это очень помогает в то время как
non-fiction как правило это факты факты
факты поэтому вот даже где вкуса
хорошо еще один вопрос согласна-согласна
и например для меня
первые такие который я читал по русски
доброта стал набирать его саванта потому
что не очень толстый .
война и мир это как маленький потом я и
других лиги я рублю и его использование
языки толстой любимый это не очень часто
очень очень хорошо для понимать
достоевский я яй то что это это ясно это
ясно ясно ясно и красивый я согласен я
очень бы чехова лично итоге тебя я твой
дом и тех людей которые изучать язык и
сказки и рассказы
мы хотим читать какие банки банки каски
это очень привлекательно когда мы
изучаем
стив есть такое понятие как быстрое
чтение и медленное чтение в какой-то
момент вот не знаю как в канаде например
украине было очень подлинно популярные
курсы скорочтения дочитать наискосок
читать больше информации больше книг за
меньшее время и так далее но что ты
думаешь по этому поводу не теряется ли
качества особенно когда мы учим
иностранный язык можем ли мы вообще себе
позволить быстро читать и надо ли
я есть я я попробовала один раз я найду
это было очень эффективно потому что тем
более мы читаем тем быстрыми будем
читать надо много читать но мой модный
носит 502 я не
и у меня есть не станет терпеть это это
как например
не manix не моника маленькое понять это
мид методика запоминания да я не будем
проводить времени
делали я буду читать вспомнить я не буду
если я из слов я слова я буду много
введите поди spoke
если не сейчас например я считаю парочки
я буду забивать и если я буду начинать
говорить или деталь будет немножко
поэтому bistritz чтения или не моника
space pro 5 6 я не очень это не значит
что это не работает может быть работает
но я попробовал и дамы сказать что ной я
не стал продолжать я ведь до продажи
я не стал продолжать тоже вы так чтение
настолько мощный инструмент для
запоминания вот как ты думаешь почему
люди человечество забыло о нем почему
человечество придумывают все новые и
новые системы мнемонику и так далее но
чтение то что существовала веками или
забыли но и дождь это но мама что люди
что угодно и дуги будет думать новый
system система как бегать более быстрее
карт не значит есть здоровье думаю
ночи таня как тебя не будет существовать
будет продолжать но меня электронные
книги
это очень удобно есть выбор еще один 2
гомель мы можем зависит от ситуации я
путешествую я обязательно читаю не
kinder это удобно для изучения языка
языков языках это удобно но если на и и
еще один
мы не можем я не думаю что это хороший
то же самое содержание мое море
используя из использовать много способ
много прочих разные подходы вот разные
подходы до этого я думаю что читать
книги читать и слушать подкаст
книги у нас нет выбор и если мы
используем все это разный вид и мы
предпочитаем я не знаю один электронной
книги или
используй все это это двора и ты
разнообразия это очень это хорошо хорошо
добра за разного разве как ты знаешь я
популяризирую линки ул 2 метод и ко мне
приходят разные люди которые хотят
выучить разные языки и иногда когда мы
начинаем говорить выясняется что у
человека нет привычки читать даже
по-русски говорят я не читаю
ну но не читаю вот таким образом можно
людей вдохновить что лишь попробовать
развить эту привычку потому что ноги
после того как проходит курс со мной
того как по занимается beauty у них
привычка развивается в начале они
скептически относятся нет я лучше буду
видео смотреть я буду смотреть сериалы и
тогда читать или меня чтобы ты сказал
таким людям но во первых видео
ты обязательно должен сидеть и
посмотреть 1 час 1 час видео по этому
видео это не очень удобно это не очень
портабельная
это не очень портативны мы говорим
портативна это не портатив
читать и так не только в украине и
много людей не хотят читать может выйти
в школах они не очень хорошо читаю читал
я не знаю до меня сам но [ __ ]
изучение языков языках и так и так
языка либо языков это это это самый
мощный способ 4 самый мощный
мощный мощный бас
но чтобы быть я не знаю вы не можем я не
начну с 4-я и начинает слушание и когда
я слышу его и слушание я могу это
машине вы когда я гуляю
что вы это самый удобный самый
портативный способ изучения
слышу это случае это и и у нас сегодня
mp3 есть много чего это на мая iphone
меня есть огромное бьет и 15 языков я
могу и и как вы думаю 20 лет назад в
каждой школы
украине в коране дам я вечный библиотеки
много павшая ты прикалываются
лингафонные кабинеты регара фонарик у
клиента большие наушники вот так и
сейчас все
и альфа сужение это это самый богатый
когда я слушаю я не зря не понимаю или я
понимаю 20 процентов 30 50 процентов но
я хочу читать я хотел знать что то что
это содержание и поэтому я как я начинаю
слышать я служил и по немножку нос
пытается делать а потому что это что вы
знать без и самый быстрый способ это
чьи-то не и я слушаю потом я читаю
который слова которые я не знаю конечно
еще я сохраняю
и помнешь купаве ножку я начинаю
понимать это это язык на это начинается
за слышание это совершенствовать и
завершаются это зарождается жить они и
после того что я это читал может пить
много раз и еще слово я и потом я слушаю
и
и и все такой не все таки не понимаю
хотя я и читал я искал слово я схожу и
потом я слушаю и не понимаю потом надо
еще раз читать но если я буду продолжать
это это посмотрим дальше это у нас
добродетель добродетельный круг но
позитивный не знаю круг имея буду и это
слово добыть мозг будет привыкнуть
на это я думаю что если и даже
я думаю что если люди платят больше свою
сеть может быть любопытство стоит будет
почта другие выйдет и это сподвигнет их
читать больше
да воодушевит сподвигнет читать больше и
и я думаю что аудиокниги это это
фантасты прекрасно прекрасно и есть или
где количество и качество один очень
хорошо испанской нет испанский но
по-русски по-французски ибо сельский
поднимет фильм есть я хотел чтобы
поделиться буквально на прошлой неделе я
готовил курс для людей которые учить
турецкий и я обнаружил что старец л
без такой сайт стал у них огромная
просто огромная библиотека на очень
разных языках вплоть до хинди и арабский
турецкий португальский аудиокниг и
огромные
я поделюсь с тобой хорошо я скину ссылку
очень много книг спасли хорошем качестве
хорошие чтецы конечно у меня
если мои уровень недостаточно у меня
[музыка]
конечно
который я могу и потеряли потому что
арабский книгу по арабски
будет немножко сложно и будете бегать
даже если я понимаю 20 процентов есть
это за убийство любить свои что это
и поэтому я хочу читать но я хотел
читать
даже как вы говорили если я не знаю если
и так есть больше чем пять процентов
слов которые не знаю я боюсь этаж про
электронные виде
я могу импортирует на лень искать
интересно стив пожалуйста скажи ты
можешь назвать три книги на другом языке
которые тучу которые повлияли на твою
жизнь повлияли на тебя а ставились в
памяти больше всего fiction infection
ними значение к сожалению и когда я
читаю я очень люблю и когда это кончится
хорошо но я читали последние
последнее время российские влияние в это
очень интересно это может называться ее
и на каком языке ты читаешь это
по-английски я не помню когда я читал я
когда я изучал итальянский я люблю я
люблю к сайте и promise из позы
когда говорить говорить сказать говорить
power итальянец я читаю
носить позы это как и русские говорящих
который изо рта узких штанах
они не любит валю этом не любит но я
люблю и по-французски я люблю база
люблю
это ваш вопрос и вкус укусом
прекрасном ну это все вопросы которые
вам горин этот момент но я все таки я
будет продолжаться изучать российские
рабский и потом турецкий и когда у меня
будет потому что я не могу всегда я
немножко хуже и потом будет лучи
[смех]
стив я бы хотел попросить если можно
чтобы может быть еще раз встретимся тоже
хотя бы 1 месяц вот так выбрать какую-то
тему обсуждать , да и сегодня домой
домой русские тоже очень хорошо для
людей которые нас будут слушать потому
что я рассказываю этим и так много и
ведомо интересно увидеть и услышать что
ты думаешь с нами тогда я прощаюсь и
желаю хорошего дня у нас уже вечер и до
скорых встреч
ok все хорошего тогда да можно
заканчивать записи
тебе останется аудиозапись я параллельно
записывал еще этот эфир и я вышлю еще
одну запись вторую аки осиба
я